Hi everyone, my name is Jenny Lanier
and I'm with the IBM Cloud team.
Let's talk about how to deploy and manage
applications in IBM Cloud Code Engine.
Before we begin, let's first talk
about what an "application" is.
An application is any piece of code that is
typically meant to run and respond to incoming
requests - such as a web server. While it is
also possible to have an application running
even without incoming requests, we're
going to focus on the more common case.
With that definition, let's jump
right into deploying an application.
From this Code Engine "overview" page you'll see
that you can immediately deploy a container image
that you've already built by
using this "quick start" dialog.
You'll see that the image name is pre-populated
with a sample container image name, so
let's just go ahead and hit "Start creating".
On this page you'll see there are some
options available, but let's keep this
really simple, just using the defaults for
everything, including the name of the application.
So, since we're not going to change anything,
let's just go ahead and hit the
"Create" button to actually do it.
Deploying the app will take a second or two, so
let's discuss what's going on behind the scenes.
First, Code Engine will download the image
you provided and then deploy that to the Code
Engine runtime. Since applications are meant
to accept requests, it will also setup all
of the networking infrastructure necessary
to route the requests to your application.
Let's go to the "Runtime" tab to see what kind of
runtime configuration options are available to us.
Notice on here you can control
things like the amount of memory
and CPU allocated for each instance of your app.
You can also control incoming
requests and automatically terminate
any request after a certain amount of time.
The "Concurrency" value controls how many
requests your app can handle at one time and
once that limit is reached, Code Engine will
create additional instances to handle the load.
Likewise, as the load decreases it will shut down
unneeded instances to automatically manage
the scaling of your application for you.
Finally, notice the final two config options
- min scale and max scale. This allows you to
control that scaling we just talked about even
down to zero instances if there are no incoming
requests - but you are in full control of the
lower and upper bounds of this scaling.
Including having a certain number of
instances always running, if needed.
Notice the app is now "ready" so let's go ahead
and see what it looks like by pressing the
"Application URL" button.
Notice the URL starts with "https", so the
application is automatically secured with TLS.
Now, let's pause here for a moment.
Think about what we just did.
We deployed a secure internet-facing
application, that will automatically
scale up and down with traffic - even to zero -
so you don`t have to pay when your app is idle.
And we did all of this with simply the
name of our container image.
If you're familiar with platforms like Kubernetes,
think about how long it would have taken you to
set up all of the infrastructure needed to do
that? The pods, deployments, replicateSets,
load-balancers, ingress... that's a lot
of work reduced down to one trivial step.
And that's the simplified developer
experience that Code Engine offers,
and to be honest, that developers should expect.
That's all the time we have for today, but
hopefully you found this quick walk-through
of how to manage applications in Code
Engine exciting and I encourage you to look
at our other videos to see more key Code Engine
features. And, of course, we hope that you'll go
to www.ibm.com/cloud/code-engine to
play with it yourself.
Thank you.